我用AI做了一条端午节短片,无故故事横跨2000年,没有演员也不需要拍摄
令我震惊的是我通过古画和资料的专项训练居然相对还原了符合年代的服装并且达到相对准确
这也侧面说明了AI影视在未来的准确讯上会越来越高
结尾我和揭秘简述我的制作流程让我们一起看看这支短片长什么样
没有, 我们去看短文化舞台
所以, 张书亚, 你是什么来说?
爹爹
爹爹, 你在哪儿?
先生, 你记这些做什么?
后人该知道, 端午不止粽子
阿娘追不上我, 阿娘追不上我
你跑那么快, 阿娘可追不上你
阿娘要追不上你
那阿娘买的粽子, 可就不分给你吃了
就一件衣裳, 值得这么高兴
战乱数十年
这件衣裳告诉我, 回家了
志同哥, 你看龙舟就看龙舟
你发什么呆啊
河流奔永不肯停
人怎么肯停啊
那你想奔到哪儿去
哪里需要我, 我就奔向哪里
呦, 曹老师
景点端午有个小生送屋猜什么
是啊, 保佑好自己平安
志同你飞机来了, 抓紧让小生娃儿息切离
语言, 镇皇考月薄欧
大腹何故至此
举世皆酌, 我毒轻
众人皆醉, 我毒醒呐
端午不止粽子, 还有家宝
竹午不止粮子, 无辜非以马外兴
竹午不止粮子, 全其不过
乱以灾, 我不足, 破我美政兵
小鬼子老子, 打死你
学生男, 离开了
秀, 我还以为你今年不回来了呢
本来没打算回的
但是听到我韩国同学都要陪家人过节
我就回来了
你这是把我和你妈当备选啊
我哪有
该影片的制作流程分为五步
1. 资料查询和脚本构思
2. 专项训练图片认证
3. 图生视频
4. AI音乐制作
5. 剪辑合成
其实这种涉及历史细节的影片
我认为最难的部分是资料查验和图片生成的部分
现在大家看到很多出自烂造的AI视频
之所以浮化到错误
是因为没有做专项训练和美术
大量运用了公共库的素材
我这里系到唐朝小孩的形象取之于古画
就连唐朝女性的跨包都是壁画还原的
东汉时期的建筑风格和服装
比如杜甫这里我就用了杜甫本人的脸
尽量也做到还原
这样公众流训练的案例
让影片真实感有所提升
还是未来AI视频精品化的流程
以上就是本期视频的全部内容
我是罐头,点赞高的话
后续我会持续分享制作干货和思路
感谢您的关注
我们下期节目再见